عود الى مستشفى الشفاء في غزه مع الناطق
باسم جهاز الدفاع المدني في القطاع الرائد
محمود بصل ارجو ان الصوت
الان واضح وتسمعني الرائد محمود فقط اردت
ان اعزيك في البدايه علمت ان والدتك
استشهدت اليوم وفي الواقع يعني نقف جميعا
احتراما لهذا الحرص و وهذا هذه القوه التي
تجعلكم تتابعون عملكم بعد هذه الاخبار
المؤلمه سواء من جانبكم من جانب ايضا
مراسلينا ومن امثله كثيره في قطاع غزه
نسمع بها واحدا تلو
الاخر رائد
محمود اسالك عن التحديات التي تواجهونها
اليوم خصوصا بعد هذا الاستهداف الكبير
الذي تابعناه في بيت لاهيه ومناطق مختلفه
مستشفى الامل كيف يمكن وصف التحديات في
هذه
المرحله نعم هو في الحقيقه بدايه يعني
الرحمه للشهداء جميعا حقيقه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي حتى هذه اللحظه يعني لازال
يمارس سياسه استهداف المنازل الماهوله
بالسكان واستهداف المباني السكنيه واطلاق
القذائف قذائف المدفعيه على منازل
المواطنين في قطاع غزه وشاهدنا جميع عن
هذه المجزره الكبيره التي حدثت في منطقه
الشمال حيث استشهد ما يزيد عن 30 مواطن في
هذه المنطقه ايضا في محافظه غزه هناك يعني
عده استهدافات وللعلم الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
في منطقه مدينه غزه كل يوم يكون هناك
عمليات قتل لمواطنين مدنيين متواجدين في
المناطق الغربيه من مدينه غزه حيث يعني
بعد عمليه الاستهداف عمليه الانسحاب
للقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بدات
المواطنين من العوده الى الى منازلهم
وبالتالي يعني كل يوم يصلنا مناشدات من من
المواطنين بان هناك يعني عمليات قنص
للمواطنين والمواطنين الان يعني حتى هذه
اللحظه متواجدين في الشوارع وصلنا اكثر من
45 يعني حاله لشهداء متواجدين في شارع
ثمانيه فقط نتيجه عمليات القنص الموجوده
في تلك المنطقه من قبل قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لمنازل المواطنين وايضا ل يعني
المواطنين الذين يسيرون في هذا الشارع
ايضا في الوسطى هناك يعني عمليات استهداف
وفي خانيونس وفي ايضا منطقه رفح وبالتالي
نتحدث عن يعني كل قطاع غزه يتعرض الى
عمليات استهداف وعمليات قتل من قبل
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يعني التحديات التي
تواجهنا حقيقه هي الامكانيات مع العلم ان
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يعني تقريبا اكثر من
ثلثي امكانيات الدفاع المدني تضررت وتدمرت
نتيجه هذه الحرب الدمويه المجنونه على
قطاع غزه وايضا يعني التحدي الكبير الذي
يواجه طواقم الدفاع المدني هو قله
الامكانيات من بالنسبه للمعدات الثقيله
والتي يعني يتم استخدامها في عمليات انقاذ
المواطنين المتواجدين في المنازل التي يتم
استهدافها يعني قبل يومين كان هناك
استهداف لمنزل وكان في داخل هذا المنزل
اكثر من 75 مواطن وللاسف الشديد ما حاولنا
انتشاله هو عدد بسيط من الشهداء لكن بقيه
هؤلاء الشهداء يعني متواجدين حتى هذه
اللحظه تحت الانقاض وبالتالي يعني التحدي
الكبير هو انه لا يوجد للاسف الشديد اي
معده ثقيله من خلالها يتم العمل على
انتشال هؤلاء الشهداء وهؤلاء طبعا ان
يضافوا الى سجل الشهداء المفقودين
المتواجدين في قطاع غزه والذي يعني عددهم
يزيد عن الاف من المواطنين المتواجدين تحت
الانقاض حتى هذه اللحظه ايضا يعني بالنسبه
ل يعني طواقم الدفاع المدني ايضا تعاني
حقيقه من نقص في الكادر البشري و وممن اول
لحظه لهذه الحرب الدمويه قلنا انه لا بد
من دفع من من رفض جهاز الدفاع المدني
بطواقم تعمل في هذا المجال من اجل ان تدخل
قطاع غزه وتقوم بمسانده طواقم الدفاع
المدني على مستوى قطاع غزه لكن للاسف
الشديد حتى هذه اللحظه لم يصلنا اي شيء
وفيما يخص ايضا الوقود لهذه المعاناه
الكبيره التي نعانيها نحن في الدفاع
المدني بعدم توفر الوقود فمنذ بدايه الحرب
منذ 7 اكتوبر حتى هذه اللحظه يعني لم يصل
جهاز الدفاع المدني اي لتر واحد من الوقود
حتى هذه اللحظه رغم يعني الحديث عن يعني
كميه متواضعه من الوقود تدخل القطاع لكن
لم يصل طواقمنا اي شيء وللاسف الشديد ايضا
الواقع حقيقه في قطاع غزه في قضيه النزوح
التي يعني تحدث للمواطنين الامنين
والمدنيين في قطاع غزه المشاهد حقيقه التي
تسجل هي مشاهد مرعبه جدا عمليات نقل
للمواطنين بشكل كبير جماعات وبشكل يعني
مذهل جدا تقوم هذه العائلات من التنقل من
اماكن الى اماكن اخرى بحثا عن الامن لكن
للاسف الشديد في غزه لا يوجد اي مكان امن
وبالتالي يعني هذا يستدعي الى تدخل دولي
حقيقه من اجل حمايه هؤلاء المواطنين
الامنين في قطاع غزه وحقيقه قيقه على
مستوى ايضا الواقع الصحي هنا يعني نتحدث
عن يعني شيء اليم جدا كل يوم يسجل عدد من
الشهداء من الجرحى الذين هم مصابين
ومتواجدين داخل المشافي المتبقيه في قطاع
غزه نتيجه قله الامكانيات ونتيجه قله
الكادر البشري وقله يعني المعدات حتى
التخصصيه التي تستخدم لعلاج هؤلاء المرضى
وهذا طبعا يعني يدفع الى ان يكون هناك
ويسجل عدد كبير من الشهداء وكل يوم
طواقمنا في الدفاع المدني في الاسعافات
تحاول يعني ان تنقل هؤلاء الشهداء من
اماكن العمليات التي يعني استشهدوا فيها
الى المقابر التي هي مخصصه لعمليات الدفن
وحتى على مستوى الدفن ايضا اليوم لا يوجد
اماكن مخصصه في قطاع غزه جميعها قد امتلات
عن بكره ابيها واليوم المواطنين يقومون
بدفن المواطنين في الشوارع وفي المدارس
وفي اي مكان ربما يكون يعني هناك مجال
لعمليات الدفن يقومون بدفن جثامين الشهداء
نتحدث عن ح حقيقه عن الاف من الشهداء
الذين دفنوا في اماكن غير مخصصه نتحدث عن
واقع اليم في قطاع غزه حتى يعني قبل
تقريبا ساعات من الان كان هناك حديث عن
انسحاب يعني بسيط من منطقه الشيخ رضوان
وتوجهت طواقمنا الى هذه المناطق نتحدث عن
دمار هائل ودمار كبير وحسب افاده
المواطنين المتواجدين في تلك المناطق
يتحدثوا حقيقه عن عذابات شاهدوها اثناء
تواجد قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في تلك
المنطقه وهذا حقيقه الامر يعني يستدعي الى
ان يكون هناك تدخل فوري وتدخل عاجل من اجل
حمايه المدنيين المتواجدين في قطاع غزه
بان يتوقف شلال الدم وتتوقف هذه المجازر
التي تحدث في قطاع غزه اجملت المشهد
الرائد محمود بصل ناطق باسم جهاز الدفاع
المدني في قطاع غزه اشكرك جزيلا كنت معنا
من مستشفى
الشفاء